Professor John Rogers:
It's been said that if
Samson Agonistes didn't
exist,
then we could say with
something like perfect
confidence that John Milton
could never have chosen Samson
for a hero.
There's very little in the
Samson story that makes sense in
terms of the larger thematic
patterns of Milton's major poems
as we have come to know them.
Think about Paradise Lost.
In Paradise Lost,
Milton struggled to justify
the ways of God to men.
He attempted to make his
religion, his faith,
as justifiable and as rational
in a lot of ways as he possibly
could.In Paradise
Regained Milton rewrote
Christian history.
He went even further,
rewriting Christian history to
scrub it clean of the primitive
and violent notion of sacrifice
in the form of the crucifixion.
Fallen man was redeemed,
we remember,
not because Christ was
sacrificed on the cross but
because of a much more rational
and arguably a justifiable
cause: man was redeemed quite
simply because the Son of God
was able to resist the
temptations of Satan.
Man was redeemed because the
Son was able to behave
rationally and obediently -- and
an unstated corollary here for
Paradise Regained is that
we can all.
We're all in a position to
redeem ourselves,
and I think this is why Milton
so scrupulously and carefully
refers to Jesus either as Jesus
or the Son,
the Son of God,
and never in Paradise
Regained as Christ.
Of course, we can't aspire to
the status of Christ,
which is the Greek word for
messiah,
which merely means "the
anointed one."
That's something that we can't
be, but as Satan knows,
all of us are sons of God.
We all have the capacity to do
pretty much what the Son of God
had accomplished in Paradise
Regained.Now,
when we approach Samson
Agonistes, we realize
pretty quickly that we have to
toss aside immediately any
expectation that Milton will be
writing a theodicy,
an attempt to justify the ways
of God.
It's impossible to imagine the
justice or the rationality
behind the primary actions of
this poem.
The first question that I think
we have to ask ourselves is what
could possibly [laughs]
have possessed Milton to have
chosen Samson,
that famous biblical hero,
for the subject of his final
work.
I'm just going to ask you for a
moment to think about Samson as
he appears in the Old Testament,
the book of Judges.
I think all biblical scholars
agree that the story of Samson
had its origins in a primitive
and savage folk tale.Samson
was a giant who slayed
Philistines with a jawbone and
who attached firebrands to the
tails of foxes in order to set
whole cities on fire.
The writer of the Judges
version of this tale -- which
comes much later,
of course,
than the original tale itself,
because it's a folk tale -- the
Judges version has done very
little to cleanse the tale of
what we can think of as its
savagery or to transform the
tale into anything that we might
think appropriate for holy
scripture.
If the Old Testament Samson can
be said to possess any virtues
that we would feel comfortable
recognizing as virtues,
it would have to be Samson's
complete abstinence from wine.
It goes without saying that we
all applaud Samson's
abstemiousness.
Surely this abstinence from
wine isn't in and of itself a
sufficient cause for Milton to
turn what is essentially a
terrorist ogre into an orthodox
hero fit for a Christian
poem.Now,
look at the front of the
handout.
This is where I reproduced the
end of the Judges version of the
Samson story,
and so according to the Hebrew
Bible these are Samson's
climactic actions at the
Philistine Festival of Dagon.
You'll remember that Samson has
been blinded,
he's been humiliated,
and he's being forced to make
sport for the Philistines;
it's a side show for the main
show.
Samson called unto the Lord and
said:
O Lord God,
remember me,
I pray thee,
and strengthen me,
only this once,
O God, that I may be at once
avenged of the Philistines for
my two eyes.
And Samson took hold of
the two middle pillars upon
which the house stood,
and on which it was borne up,
of the one with his right hand,
and of the other with his
left.
And Samson said,
Let me die with the
Philistines.
And he bowed himself with all
his might;
and the house fell upon the
lords, and upon all the people
that were therein.
Now, Samson prays to God --
yes, it's true:
he prays to God,
but look what he prays for.
He's praying for vengeance.
"Only this once…
let me be avenged upon the
Philistines," Samson prays.
In an act that can only be
called a suicide,
and it has been called a
suicide for thousands of years
now, Samson brings the house
down.
The dominant impulses here are
suicide and revenge,
and by any ethical standard
available to Milton this story
has to be seen as morally and
ethically repugnant.Now,
it's true that Milton does make
some efforts to clean the story
up, to purge the story of some
of its most morally offensive
elements.
I think that's perhaps one of
the reasons why you have all of
that violent rhetoric,
that language of purgation,
that I talked about in the last
lecture.
Nonetheless,
we simply can't deny the fact
that Samson does commit suicide
and that the suicide has the
singularly satisfying effect of
avenging the loss of Samson's
eyes.
What is so amazing about this
poem is that Samson's final
action -- an action that any
right-thinking Christian,
any right-thinking anyone,
would have to find ethically
repellant -- this final action
is approved of.
It's sanctioned by God,
Samson's murderous feelings,
his unseemly desire to get
even.
All of these questionable
motives are given a vast divine
blessing.
It's a shocking expression of
what Freud would call wish
fulfillment.
This final work of Milton seems
from a theological point of
view, from the religious
perspective,
to counter just about
everything of Milton's that
we've read up to this point.
That's because here every wish,
every desire -- all of those
passionate instincts that the
other works were laboring so
hard to suppress -- all of these
wishes just get fulfilled in
this poem.Now,
I'm not at all suggesting that
Samson Agonistes is
wholly unrelated to Milton's
other works.
That would be the last thing I
would want to suggest.
Milton's obviously imagining
the final action of this poem in
relation to the climactic
actions of his other two major
works,
and he draws all three of his
final works together by placing
their central actions at high
noon,
at mid-day.
In Paradise Lost,
Eve falls at noon and Milton
told us simply -- this is on the
handout but it's also on the
board -- Milton tells us with
exquisite economy "she plucked,
she eat."
With this extraordinary
concision, Milton narrated that
act on earth that initiates the
history of fallen man.In
Paradise Regained,
Milton describes the
action that works really to undo
the effects of Eve's fall.
That's the Son's resistance to
Satan's temptation,
as opposed to his giving in to
it as Eve had.
In narrating this event,
Milton alludes to the
grammatical structure of that
narrative crux from Paradise
Lost,
and he employs another sentence
of four monosyllabic words,
two of them active verbs:
"he said and stood."
What was a transgressive action
in Paradise Lost is
redeemed through what could be
seen as the Son's motionless
inaction,
his resistance to action,
or at least his resistance to
any form of heroic action as it
is typically conceived.Now,
in Samson Agonistes,
Milton simply can't resist
the opportunity to complete this
triad of momentous actions.
He can't resist this
opportunity to remind his
readers, us, of his other two
great major poems.
So when Samson pulls down the
pillars of the temple,
Milton describes that action
with a closely related
grammatical construction -- four
words,
two of them verbs:
"he tugg'd, he shook."
I want you to pause just for a
moment and to think about how --
when we consider this sequence,
how shocking that sentence is.
With this final catastrophic
action Milton seems to take back
everything that the Son of God
had accomplished in Paradise
Regained -- this has to be
one of the most regressive
conclusions in all of English
literature.
The Son of God had devoted all
four books of Paradise
Regained to resisting
action, to resisting vulgar,
militaristic,
violent action.
He simply did nothing,
and he was so adamant in his
resistance that Satan was led,
you'll remember,
to cry out with complete
exasperation,
"What dost thou in this world?"
The answer to the question was
that the Son does absolutely
nothing in this world,
or he does absolutely nothing
except obey the will of
God.But at his climactic,
high-noon action Samson seems
-- it's amazing.
Samson seems also to be obeying
the will of God,
but his action has a much
stronger resemblance to that
transgressive act of the willful
Eve.
Eve had followed her own desire.
She had followed her own
instinct when she made the fatal
decision to eat the fruit.
Here at the end of Milton's
career, it's as if Milton were
allowing himself to rethink
perhaps the theological
implications of Eve's action.
It's as if Eve's act were being
re-imagined this time as a
heroic one.
In this remarkable exercise in
wish fulfillment,
Samson gets to perform his
Eve-like transgression,
but with a big difference:
with the magical blessing of
divine sanction.
"He tugg'd, he shook":
he performs an action at least
as transgressive as Eve's,
but it's not followed by any of
the hideous consequences of
Eve's plucking and eating.
It's as if Milton were saying
to God, "Only this once,
only this once let an action as
bold as Eve's meet with your
approval."Look at Milton's
description of the destruction
of the temple.
This is line 1643 of Samson
Agonistes and it's at the
bottom of page 590 of the
Hughes. According to the
messenger who reports the event,
Samson tells the assembled
Philistines in the huge theater:
"Now of my own accord
such other trialI mean to
show you of my strength,
yet greater;As with amaze
shall strike all who
behold."This utter'd,
straining all his nerves he
bow'd;As with the force of
winds and waters pentWhen
Mountains tremble,
those two massy PillarsWith
horrible convulsion to and
froHe tugg'd,
he shook,
till down they came,
and drewThe whole roof
after them, with burst of
thunder…
Milton's language here of this
thunderous trembling,
this horrible convulsion,
is essentially the language of
apocalypse.
He's imagining the scene of
destruction as if it were
something akin to the end of the
world,
and the destruction of the
temple functions here as if it
were a type, or a forerunner,
of God's final destruction of
the world at the end of
time.Now the Samson story
from the Old Testament is an
event that clearly occurred
before the Son of God's
redemption of man from the New
Testament that Milton depicts in
Paradise Regained;
but there's some remarkable
sense in which this text
describes an event in Christian
history that happens after the
events of Paradise Regained.
In a strange and inverted
kind of way, Samson Agonistes
describes the fulfillment,
the culmination,
of the events that were laid
out in Paradise Regained.
You can see that the last three
works seem to sketch in
something like chronological
order -- even though the stories
they tell themselves are not in
chronological order,
they sketch in chronological
order the outlines of Christian
history.
"She plucked,
she ate": we have a
representation of the Fall.
"He said and stood":
we have a representation of the
redemption.
"He tugg'd, he shook":
we have something like a
representation of the
apocalypse.
Samson Agonistes in some
ways is imagining itself in
terms of the closure of a larger
thematic pattern in Milton's
literary career,
and the astonishing thing about
this final action is that it's
so completely transgressive from
any ethical or theological
perspective.Look at line
1643,
the first line I just read at
the scene of the temple.
This is Samson:
"Now of my own accord such
other trial / I mean to show you
of my strength,
yet greater."
Samson is in no way here
attributing -- as we think he
should -- he's not attributing
any of his strength or any of
his actions to God.
You remember the Son of God was
always hungering to do the
Father's will.
He was attributing everything,
and rightly so,
to the Father,
but Samson doesn't credit
Jehovah with anything here.
He's not even claiming to
perform this action for the
greater glory of God.I think
it is possible to read this as
an entirely personal act of
revenge,
and I'm personally convinced
that Milton is alluding in these
lines to that magnificent speech
that Satan had made just before
the war in heaven.
This is the speech right after
Satan had claimed to Abdiel that
he was "self-begot," self-made,
"by our own quick'ning
power…"
Satan had said to Abdiel:
"Our puissance is our own,
our own right hand / shall
teach us highest deeds…"
In claiming to make a show of
strength solely of his own
accord, Milton's Samson in a lot
of ways seems to be echoing
Milton's Satan.
He's reasserting Satan's
sublime but, of course,
completely disastrous bid for
something like an absolute self-
sufficiency.
But there's a difference,
and the [laughs]
difference is that Samson's
claim to be entirely
self-sufficient just meets with
all of God's approval.
It's the damnedest thing.
At certain moments it almost
seems as if the character of
Samson is the character of Satan
simply rewritten as the good
guy.Now,
in reading Samson
Agonistes, we're
witnessing something like an
incredible release from all of
the laws and all of the
constraints and all of the
divine ordinances that Milton
had been representing for us
throughout the earlier works.
The other poems from Comus
on are all about the
importance of the obedience to
divine law,
but Samson Agonistes is
all about God's special
dispensation to break the law.
Think about it:
Samson is permitted to break
the divine law forbidding the
marriage to a Philistine.
He does this twice.
He's permitted to break the law
that forbids the presence of
Hebrews at the Philistine
festival of Dagon.
Samson's actions simply break
through every conceivable legal
and moral constraint and all of
-- why?
Why does he get to do that?
All of Samson's behavior,
I think, has ultimately to be
laid at the door of God,
and in this case,
it's an unjustifiable or an
irrational or inscrutable
God.Look at Samson's
explanation of his first
marriage.
He was married before the
marriage to Dalila and this was
his marriage to the woman of
Timna.
Look at line 219 of
Samson, this is
page 557.
The Hebrews had a law against
marrying outside of the tribe --
still a big deal,
many people would say.
The chorus asks Samson why it
is he doesn't marry a Hebrew
wife.
[laughs] I love this question.
The chorus asks,
"Why thou shouldst wed
Philistian women…?"
Samson responds -- this is line
219:
The first I saw at Timna,
and she pleas'dMee,
not my Parents,
that I sought to wed,
The daughter of an Infidel:
they knew notThat what I
motion'd was of God;
I knewFrom intimate
impulse, and therefore
urg'dThe Marriage on;
that by occasion henceI
might begin Israel's
Deliverance…
I think we are being invited to
ask, "Well, how did Samson know
that he was motioned of God to
marry the woman of Timna?
By what sign did God make this
approval known?"
Samson answers our question and
his response is an important
one: "I knew / from intimate
impulse."
Wouldn't it be wonderful if we
could answer questions [laughs]
like that with such an answer,
"I knew / from intimate
impulse"?
It's important because this
phrase, "intimate impulse,"
surely implies a sexual passion,
a sexual impulse,
as readily as it does anything
like a mysterious impulsion from
God.The big question still
remains: how can you tell the
difference?
Samson Agonistes is the
only one of Milton's last works
to imagine a world in which God
is neither visible or audible.
On some level he had been
visible in Paradise Lost,
he was no longer visible
but he was audible in
Paradise Regained,
and now he's none of those
things.
The deity simply doesn't assert
himself anywhere authoritatively
in this text,
and of course that's one of the
reasons why Milton chose to
write this piece in a theatrical
form,
a dramatic form,
in which God couldn't possibly
be seen as a character.
The only evidence we have for
the presence of a divine will at
all is the extremely equivocal
evidence of Samson's intimate
impulse.
Milton won't let us know
absolutely whether Samson is
really inspired by God to
destroy the Philistines or
whether he's crazy and just
thinks he's inspired by God to
kill the Philistines.Milton
knows that there's nothing like
incontrovertible evidence to
prove that Samson is a divinely
inspired freedom fighter,
a freedom fighter rather than a
terrorist, or what seems at the
end of the poem to be something
-- I don't know.
We would have to call him
something like a suicide bomber.
This is why the critical
controversies surrounding
Samson Agonistes -- a set
of controversies that have been
surrounding the poems for about
twenty years now -- why they
really came to a head almost
immediately after 9/11.
That Milton could be seen to
sanction a single man's
destruction of thousands of
people,
an act that might only be
imagined to be divinely
authorized when there's no
evidence in the text that it is
absolutely,
definitively divinely
authorized, had come to seem
more troubling than ever after
9/11.
Of course,
Milton is not anywhere
sanctioning mass slaughter,
but he is insisting that
there's never anything in the
world like definitive proof of
God's authorization of anything.
We just have to believe in our
authorization.
It's Milton's amazing reticence
in this regard that set off,
after 9/11, a kind of panic
among certain Miltonists.
John Carey, the distinguished
Miltonist at Oxford,
the Miltonist at Oxford
-- and you know this from the
piece that was included in the
packet -- John Carey had been
pushed to a -- I don't know,
I think a risible,
maybe even a hysterical,
critical stance toward this
text by Milton's unwillingness
to proclaim on the question of
Samson's authority to kill so
many people.In Milton's
other poems -- and,
it goes without saying,
in the real world of all of our
everyday lives -- one is simply
not permitted to act upon all of
one's inmost impulses and
desires.
We're constantly being called
upon to be rational and to
resist those temptations for the
greater goal of the obedience to
the law.
The Son in Paradise Regained
was able to begin his work
of Israel's deliverance by
suppressing his hunger,
by suppressing his passion,
and by suppressing even his
interest in the beauty of
classical civilization;
but Samson, who certainly in
this text something like a type
of Christ, begins Israel's
deliverance by acting on his
hungers,
by acting on his passions and
desires.
The intimate stirring of his
loins might be one of those
things energizing his actions.
Milton gives us in this poem a
powerful alternative,
a scandalous alternative,
to the traditional obligation
to subordinate one's desire to
the will of God,
and in this play,
in this text,
one's deepest,
one's darkest desire turns out
in fact to be the will of
God.That's as shocking as
anything else it seems to me.
Think of Paradise Lost.
Milton's great achievement
in Paradise Lost,
and it really was a
magnificent achievement,
was to structure the poem as a
theodicy.
He took what he took to be the
irrational God of the
Judeo-Christian tradition and he
remade him into a reasonable and
justifiable embodiment of law,
to a large extent.
By the time we get to Samson
Agonistes, it's almost as if
you could feel Milton's relief,
a sigh of relief,
now that he's been released
from the pressure to write a
theodyicy.
"Thank God!"
you can hear Milton saying.
"I don't have to write a
theodicy anymore.
I don't have to justify God
anymore!"
Here at the end of Milton's
career, you have something like
an extraordinary release from
all of the strictures of justice
and all of the strictures of
reason that Milton had set for
himself and that Milton had
submitted himself
to.According to the
Aristotelian theory of tragedy,
the climax of a tragedy is
supposed to be cathartic for the
viewer, or perhaps for the
reader -- originally for the
viewer.
It's supposed to purge or to
release all of those pent-up
passions in the audience.
But I think there's a way in
which the climax of Samson
Agonistes functions as much
as a catharsis for the poet as
it does for the reader.
Look again at page 591 -- this
is line 1647.
I think we have an image here
of this cathartic release as it
has been inscribed by Milton
into the poem itself within that
passage that we just looked at.
At the very moment that Samson
acts of his own accord and
brings the massive pillars down,
here at line 1647,
"As with the force of winds and
waters pent / when Mountains
tremble,"
and then "he tugg'd, he shook."
When Samson pulls the pillars
down it's as if a dam were
breaking.
The force of winds and waters
that have been pent or penned up
have suddenly been released,
and you can see an emblem,
I think, for the powerful
release that Milton is allowing
his own religious imagination.
Milton's water has broken and
it's as if he were giving birth
to yet another fantasy theology,
this theology just being that
much more fantastic than
anything he had come up with
before.
This is essentially a theology
that Milton's contemporaries
would have called antinomian.
He's generated a text in which
divine will isn't ever opposed
to human desire;
God's will and man's will are
simply the same thing -- nice
work if you can get it.Now,
there has been another release
in the Miltonic imagination as
well.
In Samson's show of strength at
the festival of Dagon,
you have an act of sacrifice
that saves the Hebrews from
their Philistine oppressors.
Samson's sacrifice at the
temple has to readers for a long
time now -- and I think this
seems unmistakable -- has a
resemblance to Christ's
sacrifice on the cross.
A lot of biblical commentators,
in fact, in Milton's time
agreed that Samson's action,
because his arms are
outstretched,
was something like a
prefiguration of Christ's
crucifixion.
There is something like a sense
in which Milton in this poem is
allowing himself -- and he's
really allowing himself for the
first time here near the end of
his life -- to represent this
pivotal moment in Christian
history,
the crucifixion.
Milton, like the Bible,
has Samson's arms outstretched
on the massive pillars as if in
direct imitation of Christ's
posture on the cross.Look at
the very beginning of the poem.
Actually, look at the little
place before the very beginning
of the poem.
This is Milton's note on the
form of tragedy.
It's on page 549 of the
Hughes. This note starts
to explain why Milton has chosen
this genre,
the genre of dramatic tragedy,
for his final work.
So Milton is laboring here to
justify his decision to write a
tragedy, and he cites others who
have written tragedies
themselves.
This is a little over halfway
down -- no, this is near the
bottom of page 549.
Milton invokes Augustus Caesar:
"Augustus Cesar also had begun
his Ajax [his tragedy,
Ajax]
but unable to please his own
judgment with what he had begun,
left it unfinisht."
Look a couple of sentences down.
Milton invokes a tragedian,
Gregory Nazianzen,
Gregory Nazianzen who was able
to finish a tragedy:
Gregory Nazianzen,
a Father of the Church,
thought it not unbeseeming the
sanctity of his person to write
a Tragedy,
which he entitl'd Christ
Suffering.
I think it's clear that Milton
is thinking of the genre of
tragedy here as the literary
form best suited to the subject
of Christ's passion,
Christ's suffering on the cross.
Milton, of course,
we know had tried to represent
Christ suffering on the cross
once before.
But just like Augustus Caesar
who wasn't able to finish his
tragedy, Ajax,
the young Milton had left
his initial attempt at the story
of the Passion unfinished.
Perhaps you'll remember the
little note that Milton had
appended to that early poem,
"The Passion," that we
read at the beginning of the
semester.
The poem just ends abruptly,
you'll remember,
and Milton writes:
"This Subject the Author
finding to be above the years he
had,
when he wrote it,
and nothing satisfied with what
was begun, left it unfinisht."
Well, here at the end of his
life, Milton's finally able to
finish the unfinished poem,
"The Passion." Samson
Agonistes ends with that
magnificent line,
"and calm of mind all passion
spent."
That line speaks on one level
to the fact -- it speaks on many
levels, but on one level it
speaks to the fact that Milton
has finished "The Passion,"
that Milton has finally
acquitted himself of the debt
that he incurred when he left
that earlier poem,
"The Passion,"
unfinished.Now,
we're left to wonder why Milton
is able finally to represent an
act of sacrifice not unlike
Christ's sacrifice on the cross.
Why suddenly is this heretofore
unrepresentable event
representable?
I think Milton's able to
complete this representation of
the crucifixion because he's
been able entirely to re-imagine
the dynamics of sacrifice.
Now in the New Testament in the
Gospel of John,
we're told that God so loved
the world that he gave his only
begotten son to save that world.
The Father willingly sacrificed
the Son, but in Samson
Agonistes the hero
sacrifices himself.
Samson sacrifices himself of
his own accord,
as he tells us,
in fulfillment of his own
private motives,
in fact, and it's only once
Milton can supply the act of
sacrifice with something like a
complete sense of
self-determination that finally
he can admit it into his poetic
canon.I think this poem is
completely overwhelmed by events
that had previously been left
unfinished or suppressed in
Milton's earlier works.
If I'm right about that,
we shouldn't be surprised to
see the resurfacing of another
desire that had so consumed
Milton at earlier stages in his
career,
and that is the desire for fame.
You remember what Milton had
written to his friend,
Diodati, in 1637.
Milton had written:
"You asked me what I am
thinking of?
So help me God,
an immortality of fame," the
young, twenty-nine-year-old
Milton had written,
but he soon corrected himself.
In "Lycidas" fame was
denigrated as "that last
infirmity of the noble mind,"
and in Paradise Regained
it's denigrated even
further.
Fame was a temptation offered
by Satan to the Son of God that,
of course, the Son of God was
able to reject without
wincing.But here at the end
of Samson,
the prospect of earthly
fame -- I'm talking about good,
old-fashioned secular fame --
is granted the dead Samson and
is granted to him without the
slightest apology.
It's Samson's earthly father,
Manoa, who labors to ensure his
son's fame.
Look at the last page of the
poem.
This is page 593.
Manoa says at the top of the
page:
[I w]ill send for all my
kindred, all my friendsTo
fetch him ["him" is the dead
body of Samson]
hence and solemnly
attendWith silent obsequy
and funeral trainHome to his
Fathers house…
I'll interrupt myself here just
for a moment because I'm going
to ask you to think of the
possible counterpoint that that
line that I've just read has
with the end of Paradise
Regained,
"Home to his Mother's house
private" he "return'd."
Manoa continues:
[T]here will I build
himA Monument,
and plant it round with
shadeOf Laurel ever green,
and branching Palm,With all
his Trophies hung,
and Acts enroll'dIn copious
Legend,
or sweet Lyric Song.
Now, the "shade / Of Laurel
ever green" is not an honor
typically bestowed upon the
great biblical heroes,
but it is an honor bestowed
upon great poets -- at least,
in the classical tradition.
That's why we have the phrase
poet laureate.
You have in this incredibly
moving tribute that Manoa has
given Samson the promise of
eternal fame that has been the
desire of great poets as long as
there have been great poets.
The monument built for Samson
here is something like a
displaced version of Milton's
own monument.
Maybe this is a moment that can
compete with the "livelong
monument" that Milton had
imagined that was the monument
of Shakespeare,
Shakespeare's tomb,
of which the young Milton had
written in his first published
poem.Now,
as you can see from the bottom
of the handout,
from the passage taken from one
of the earliest biographies of
Milton -- and this is also
included in the Hughes --
"Milton at his death was buried
at the churchyard at Cripplegate
where about thirty years before
he had,
by chance, also interred his
father."
Like Samson's body at the time
of his death,
the body of John Milton was
returned, as it were,
home to his father's house.
Now we're told here very
carefully that this happened by
chance, but it's surely not a
leap to assume that Milton was
himself responsible for the
instructions for his place of
burial and that he was thinking
on some level of the burial of
Samson when he arranged to have
himself buried next to his
father,
or near his father.
It's as if by returning to the
father's house,
Milton could guarantee for
himself the promise of fame that
had been bestowed upon
Samson.Look at the middle
quotation on the handout.
As John Aubrey wrote in his
Life of Milton,
Milton had during his lifetime
achieved a considerable measure
of fame;
he didn't have to wait for
after his death.
According to Aubrey,
for several foreigners -- and I
love this detail,
it's wild to imagine -- for a
lot of foreigners coming over
into England in the seventeenth
century,
the only inducement to make the
trip was to see John Milton.
More specifically,
the inducement for foreigners
to come to England was to see
the house and chamber where he
was born.
It's like a tourist attraction.
This is, of course,
the father's house,
and in his life,
the Milton home had become this
Mecca just like the one that
Manoa is planning for
Samson.Now,
one of the reasons,
I think, for which we love or
for which we hate the poetry or
anything about John Milton
involves the degree to which he
wrote about himself.
Milton, I think,
more than any other poet --
certainly any other poet before
him -- has invited,
I think, a unique fascination
with the intimate habits of his
mind and for some of us,
even a unique fascination in
his daily life at home.
I think the desire of Milton's
readers, or a lot of Milton's
readers, to imagine the poet at
home is an interesting one.
At least, that's one way to
explain the strange,
and for me the wonderful,
artifact that I photocopied for
you on the other side of the
handout.
This is a document that I used
to receive -- it's a version of
a document that I used to
receive every couple of years
from the Friend's of Milton's
Cottage group in America.
It's the form letter
representing the now
long-standing movement to raise
funds in order to restore what
is the only surviving house that
Milton actually lived in -- and
its website is something like
miltonscottage.com.
You can find information about
how to get there and so on and
so forth if you're
interested.This is the
cottage at Chalfont St.
Giles that Milton had moved to
in the 1660s when the plague was
sweeping through London.
The organization dedicated to
restoring this house is known as
The Friends of Milton's Cottage.
The president of this group,
as you can see,
was -- I don't believe he's the
president anymore -- was one Dr.
Ronald G.
Shafer, and he used to send
Miltonists just this fundraising
letter every few years.
I mention this curious artifact
not at all because I'm asking
you to give to the cause -- I
think the cottage is probably in
good shape at this point -- but
I offer it to you to give you a
sense of the peculiar impact
that John Milton has had on his
readers.
I think that impact can be
measured by something like the
almost pagan desire to
memorialize the physical
presence of this heroic poet
that has seized so many of his
readers.Now,
of course the ostensible
project here,
as you can see from the
handout, is simply to restore
Milton's home,
but I'm convinced that there's
something profounder going on,
and it's the deeper project
informing a labor of love like a
restoration project such as this
one.
I think that the underlying
desire really behind such a
project is -- and of course this
would only be unconscious or
it's a kind of fantasy project
-- but it's the desire to return
Milton to his home.
The Friends of Milton's Cottage
are just like the friends that
Manoa mentions in that final
speech at line 1730:
I "will send for all my
kindred,
all my friends / to fetch him
hence…
/ …home to his Father's
house."
It chokes me up.
There's something so moving
about Manoa's plea and there's
something, for me,
moving about Dr.
Ronald G.
Shafer's plea.The relation,
for me at least,
is that there's something about
Milton,
just as there's something about
Samson, that resists ascension
and resists transcendence --
just by all of the talk of
heaven the actual corporeal body
seems so stubbornly to remain.
You remember that that was the
case in "Lycidas" to a
large extent,
and it's this case in the final
poem as well,
written thirty years later.
I think there's something
profoundly Miltonic about our
own materialist interests in
Milton,
an interest that keeps coming
back to the bodily facts of his
life and his home and his
everyday surroundings but --
more generally than that and
more importantly than that -- an
interest in the material facts,
the fact of materiality of
everyone's life and of life
itself.
The importance,
the value and the beauty of the
physical is one of the things
that we learn,
that we get from a reading of
John Milton.Now,
if I have been unorthodox in
some of these lectures -- and I
would be deeply ashamed to think
that I haven't been at least a
little [laughs]
unorthodox -- it's been in my
sharing with you my fascination
with Milton's life and Milton's
biography.
Well, actually,
I think it's my interest in
Milton's own extraordinary
tendency to write
autobiographically.
There's an unparalleled
self-absorption at the heart of
Milton's writing,
and this sublime
self-absorption,
I think, of so many of these
texts demands something like an
equally passionate absorption in
the life of the person who
authored those texts.
Like the foreigners who
traveled to England during
Milton's own lifetime,
I have found myself pursuing
Milton with a kind of -- and
maybe it's creepy,
maybe it's not;
you can decide -- but with a
certain voyeurism.
Something in me has always
wanted to peer in to Milton's
house and chamber,
or at least to think of these
poems in some way as Milton's
house and chamber.
If I've managed to arouse in
you even the slightest tendency
to this sort of critical
voyeurism,
then on some level I feel that
I will have accomplished
something.
And so I want to end this
semester by thanking you for the
enormous efforts that you've put
into this class.
For a lecture class,
I know that this requires a lot
of work.
I want to thank you more
generally for the work that you
have performed,
and I take this work to be the
intellectual equivalent of the
restoration project undertaken
by Dr.
Ronald G.
Shafer: the work that you
performed in restoring the
greatest -- if not the home,
then the greatest of all
English poets himself.
So I will see you all at the
exam, but before I sign off,
we have to thank our two
perfectly magnificent teaching
fellows,
whom I am going to embarrass by
asking them to stand up just so
we can applaud them and
acknowledge them:
David Currell and Matt
Valdiviez.